when we were on set let's be honest it
was a magical fun experience
hello everyone hola mis amigos you're
listening to
oh my god
with me george lopez
[Music]
oh my god hi
[Applause]
uh do you have an intro down i don't
have an intern down but i know who okay
thanks for showing up prepared man
i only told you on [ __ ] friday that
this is going to be happening well i
know but i
i know who in between [ __ ] love
sessions with your old lady how many
times you guys and this is
this is a faith-based question how many
times did you guys make love this
weekend
uh only once but we did start this week
off uh
megan this morning this morning this
dude and you know you married you know
you're engaged right no i'm married
yeah yeah ross is married i'm not
um but don't feel good for me having a
baby
right speaking of um
right having a baby and your wife is uh
is she russian
so she's german from kentucky
from kentucky she's like espinoza
kentucky's well i mean okay let's stick
to the movie though but we could do a
little bit of that
uh walking with herb is something that i
think most people would describe as
a faith-based movie and while i think
about face bait
damn and while i think of movies that
are faith-based
um it's its own genre but in thinking
about movies ross like
almost every movie could be considered
something based
in faith you know wizard of oz
um oh yeah yeah you know
uh things that you aspire to be
better than they are when you start at a
place yeah
i've always called it inspirational you
know an inspirational film
like the blind side say you know
was the blind side was the thing was the
blind side considered faith-based
blindside was considered an
inspirational film
they they call faith-based and that's
been one of the challenges with our film
as you know from the beginning
is the faith-based is typically
associated with christian
a heavily christian faith-based
jesus-oriented film
whereas our film was written by
an agnostic and mark metoff a great
screenwriter
but he didn't believe in god and so we
uh created something that was what we
call the faith-based film for all faiths
so it wasn't just a christian-based film
you the dog that george has in the film
his
dog has a collar and on the collar is
the star of david is the cross is the
symbol of buddha
is we have about six different religions
represented
in in george's character so the idea is
that his character
appears as a messenger of god not just
to a christian
but to anyone of any faith and so brian
can tell you we had some challenges
in terms of distribution because people
were confused
how can you make a faith-based film that
isn't a christian
film and and our film really um
is more that's why i called an
inspirational film because the
faith-based term
was a little bit of uh confusing for
the faith-based distributors well i want
to say that
i think it's very narrow-minded
to only believe that a faith has to be
attached to a religion
and i get it right but in all of those
things and i think everybody will
remember seeing
what's on the dog's collar like the star
david the om
the buddhist symbol the cross and
everything and there was a bumper
sticker maybe
in the 70s that simply said coexist
yep yeah yes and it had those things
now and that was our that was our guide
for the dog's collar
that that bumper sticker that's what we
talked about with the with the property
people
right yep and you know um
you know we talked about the churches
that are arenas
where before churches weren't
like arenas you know when we went
through
texas and houston and all those things
and off the freeway
the driver would say you see that right
there i said who plays there the rockets
they say no man that's a that's a church
and it
it might be 15 000 people
yeah and it's packed on every sunday and
you know they
yeah and those people i think if you say
because there might be some opposition
to
if those people are against me
for my public views that they might not
be interested in seeing this film
because they might think that
you know it's they just don't like me as
a person but this movie
is is really really good
and um i know that it can't be
easy to make i know that it wasn't easy
to make
how did you guys how did uh you guys
meet
me how did ross and i yeah so so funny
enough
you know i was the chairman of the board
for the santa fe film festival
can you guys hear me yeah i was the
chairman of the board for the santa fe
film festival
and ross uh and mark medoff had come in
this is 2014
to get an award and funny enough we're
sitting down at a dinner at a tequila
bar
that was sponsored and uh ross is
sitting across from me we're eating
dinner
mark medoff's wife stephanie met off
sitting right next to me
and then marked this way and stephanie
and i start chit chatting
just about life and then she says uh
this
this young man mark is a talent
manager right right
this young man is a talent manager mark
and you need
a talent manager and mark i think says
i don't i don't think i do and she says
no no he does
he does he does so we all started
chatting and by the end of dinner
uh i was representing ross and mark and
that's actually what happened in 2014
right
wow so mark maddow for the audience uh
is the screenwriter and producer of
walking with herb
he uh uh won the academy award and tony
award for children lesser god
and this film walking with her mark was
my
mentor then my partner my father-in-law
and mark passed away uh in
post-production so this is actually the
last
thing he ever worked on and the most
meaningful part of the film for me is at
the very end when the film's ending
and the before the credits come up we
have on screen in love ring memory of
mark metoff so the film is dedicated to
mark
and he was so so proud of this film so
proud and such a talented amazing writer
and we are sitting with uh we want to
make sure everybody knows uh the
executive producer and director of
walking dead
[ __ ] that make sure you sit your ass
down okay
man i mean
when you see it's going to be emotional
when you see uh
mark come to the set um clearly looking
very ill from chemotherapy
and and yeah and um
swollen and you know just weak
but he was ross really
very happy every day that he got to see
this coming to life man and you know
nothing
really makes me happier than
either before or after to go over to
where he was sitting
at him you know rub my back and say man
you know you're just
making all of these words sing and i'm
like this guy
you know clearly is not gonna get better
i think his his daughter was amazing in
it as well
she was fantastic jessica met off place
you know when we were shooting
uh mark would come to the set as often
as he could as you said he was very very
ill and had a hard time
uh you know physically making it to the
set and eddie almost said to me after
one of the scenes
he whispered to me he said you know
mark's not going to be around
for the premiere of the movie and at the
time i didn't realize how sick he was i
guess i knew i was in denial i guess
really
and when eddie said that to me it really
really hit me like a ton of bricks
and it became even more important that
this movie be as
great as it could possibly be and if i i
was given 110
and suddenly when eddie said that to me
it was 180
because i knew that we just we owed it
to mark to make this a great movie
um he you know he worked so hard in the
script and was so proud of the script
and the interesting thing is
mark was agnostic and didn't believe in
god but through the process of making
this movie
he became a bit more of a believer
and on his deathbed he he started
really um accepting the fact that there
is
something out there greater than all of
us that will
guide him to a better place when he
finally passed were you with him when he
passed
i very i very much was yeah he was in a
hospice
and the hospice nurse was listening for
a heartbeat
she'd say yep he's still here 30 seconds
later she'd listen yep he's still here
30 seconds later she put the stethoscope
on his chest and he said he's gone
so i was there literally as he took his
last breath it was
it was just overwhelming yeah
uh yeah i mean how
what did he what did he see how far how
far
were we uh with this movie
he he he saw uh you know as you know in
in post-production a movie you do many
many
cuts in many different versions and so
we were probably
in the middle of picture edit
so um he got he got to see he didn't see
visual facts he didn't hear the score of
the movie and
uh any of that but he was able to give
me some notes you know i this was
the fourth movie mark and i did together
so
we we've done you know three previous
movies so we really
worked very closely and had a shorthand
so
for him to leave me and leave us
in the middle of post-production was
really very hard because i was used to
working hand in hand with him um on all
the projects so
uh it was it was really difficult
um post-production was really really
difficult what what are those other
what are those other three movies we did
a film called
homage the homage that fought based on a
play of is called the homage of fouls
with blythe danner and frank whaley
and bruce davison and uh won an award at
sundance
we did another movie called uh showdown
unreal road
which you may remember robbie benson uh
oh yeah we did and then we did a film
called the heart out right which is also
based on the stage play of marx
uh and then walking with herb um
so we did we did four films together um
yeah this this
this interview is gonna be long and then
we'll you know uh trim it up and stuff
uh brian describe uh the book walking
with urban if you can
remember uh when did you first hear
about it
yeah definitely so so the book is really
a
you know a faith-based you know novel
that that uh joe bullock who's our
executive producer
he wrote you know that was his
brainchild and it was a little different
from when we looked at it and i remember
this must have been in about early 2017
ross and mark had called me and said we
found this amazing book from a local
writer
that's faith-based and we want to make
this can you read it and take a look at
it and i said you know sure
so of course i read the book and i said
you know what there's a fantastic story
here but the story we ultimately landed
up making is a little different right
from from the book it varies right and
uh
we went through a period where we were
taking the book out
and just shopping it to studios early on
to say mark medoff will write this ross
marks will direct this
can you essentially underwrite the
development of this
and the faith-based world
is kind of you know hollywood is small
right you you have your same people
you're running into
a lot of the time especially in the
executive level but the faith-based area
is the same but even tinier so you only
had three buyers
okay right and you what are those what
are the three buyers
so i mean at the time it's lions gate
it's sony
and it's pure flix and maybe let's throw
in a fourth maybe universal
is trying to get into it they're doing a
little bit of it but it's not fully
there they're not committed yet
what is the most popular faith-based
movie to date as we sit here
that's i would say i can only imagine
it's actually it's the passion of the
christ
oh you're right it is you're absolutely
right which we'll get over
500 million dollars but uh pure flix
george
who who ultimately became our
distributor
embraced the film did a a movie called
god is not dead
uh which did over 100 million dollars
wow
and i think they've done what three or
four sequels to that yeah they did and
they have another one coming out now
with the name
pureflix just i was in seattle a long
time ago on tour almost said like 2007
did they start out as a company where
you put quarters in to watch the movie
in those little booths
because pure flick sounds like
that's a good question they're running
out there telling the dude you know hey
man i need five dollars or more you know
that
it costs 125 to see that movie um
yeah did you get kicked out of that
booth and
i didn't have that thing yeah i did yeah
he got kicked out of one of those peep
shows with another guy yeah i went there
we were on the road were you trying to
mop you grabbed the mop or something and
threw
us out no uh that was the guy who was
with us and uh it was the dirtiest place
we've ever been to in our life i don't
know why we walked in there and we went
to a peep show because we hadn't been to
one in 30 years and then
one of the guys cut his hand on a mop
and we're like
you're gonna die this is the dirtiest
place i've ever been to am i laughing
you have an open wound
oh yeah i don't know i don't know
whatever happened to him um
you know i was a little concerned about
this movie when you guys came to me
and you said oh edward james almost has
agreed to be in it
right and then i was golfing and i
i really hadn't talked to eddie i mean
i've known him since 88 so we go through
periods where you know we don't see each
other he's working on
stuff and i said uh is this still you
and he's like who's this and i said
lopez and then he called me
i was golfing and he's like and i said
are you attached
are you attached to this movie walking
with herb
and he said uh no
that's hilarious and i said you i said
no i said no
because they told me that you worry goes
no man i i
what do you think of this did you read
the script i said i read the script with
you
in mind and since you don't know
or you haven't heard about i'm a little
concerned
and i have a story about that and then
he says let me hang up
and uh let me call you back so you could
fill in the part that's missing
yeah so i'll tell you so this is
interesting so uh
ross when we were thinking about going
out just i'm gonna give you a little bit
more context
thinking about going out with the book
someone had pitched us
george straight to play joe
right and at the time he was named joe
goodman and we said oh that's really
interesting right maybe you know george
strait country singer
faith-based movie whatever right i'm
gonna say that i think that that
i'm gonna say that i think that i would
that's a good name to throw out there
somebody throws out george strait
for this movie i would have said i can
see that right
right and then we ultimately looked at
it and ross and mark
said he's fantastic but i think we need
to do something really special
and we said what is what is that and we
said let's cast somebody hispanic
as joe right right and the reason we did
that is i i
i'm talking to you from las cruces new
mexico
and i uh i teach at new mexico state
university i teach film when i'm not
making movies so
las cruces and george has been here a
few times about 70
80 percent latinx and new mexico state
university where i teach is about 70 80
latinx and we wanted the film walking
with herb to honor our community
so we said if we're going to honor the
community we need to make the lead of
the movie latinx we need to honor that
culture we don't need to honor that
community so we
changed the character and the novel as a
caucasian male
and we changed it to a and i reason i
say latinx and i'd like you to weigh in
on this george i was teaching a class
about two years ago and i said hispanic
hispanic
and then the students said to me no no
it's it's it's
it's latinx it's not latino it's not
hispanic mr marx professor marx
you have to refer to us as latinx that's
the proper term if you're going to uh
you know
refer to us you have to refer to us
properly and then uh
recently i who were talking to brian
that got upset with me when i said
latinx
uh i i won't say the name but somebody
on our marketing team
yeah marketing team was it a yeah
and they were offended by that or or
they just didn't they were they were
offended by this are you still here
yeah i'll be quiet after this question
but
the thing with eddie so we changed it to
uh to a latinx mail
and and i had reached out to eddie
and sent him the uh the script
and on a friday and on monday he called
me said he loved it and he wanted to do
it
and then uh he called me a little bit
later and said he was
shooting something and he couldn't do it
mayans
okay what's into the that he directed
that he was doing with kathleen
no no so he had that too but he had
already finished it what happened is the
mayan schedule
felt felt uh they fell behind on the
scripts and the shooting schedule they
didn't let the network didn't like the
scripts they had
so he had to keep pushing and that's
when eddie called
and said um i he called and said i would
love to do this movie
but you guys have to move on he said you
guys have to move on from me
because i'm not going to be done in time
to shoo in
august or september i don't think yeah
but by that time
would we i thought eddie was doing the
film
and in the movie he plays this small
town banker who has a crisis of faith
who is contacted by god and god sends
his messenger
this very unusual quirky messenger
and i thought to myself what would
god's messenger looked like for a latinx
male
who would he sent and i thought he's
going to send another latinx male
right and then i knew i wanted the
character be funny so i thought
who is the funniest best latinx male
and george was my first choice he said
we've got to get george lopez to play
herb
because he is the perfect messenger of
god it's going against type which is
wonderful
and it's also appealing to eddie's
character
so we made the offer to you
and then you called eddie and at that
point that you called eddie we actually
had an offer out to martin sheen
where we were we were reversing course
with of course on the marching and eddie
calls me up i remember i was the middle
teaching a class
and my phone rang three times it was a
la number finally i stepped out of class
he said
it said he almost he said did you offer
this to george lopez i said yes i did
and he said did he say yes i said i
think he's very interesting
well if george does that i have to do it
so we've got to figure out how to make
this possible because if george is in i
i've i've got to do this movie
yeah well what happened to is is we when
ross said
i got to get george lopez you were the
first choice right i got to get george
and i actually said you know what
i know jason heyman he's an old buddy
right and he's your agent right right
and so we we call uh jason and jason's
like yeah let me let me take a read
and then and it luckily got to you and
you got to see it but ross is right
you you talked to ross i think you read
it and we set up a
phone meeting right and after you got
off that phone meeting
eddie called uh ross and ross had called
me and said
hey he just said george told them he
wants to do it and he's back in
and that's how it came together um yeah
that's
i mean martin sheen it's funny when you
look at
you know who could have been and then
you say
well martin sheen is an incredible actor
uh
you know he would have been able to do
it would he have been able to pull off
the golfing part
i don't know because i mean usually
golfers
i mean somebody played ben hogan and the
sun always rises or his movie
forgot who did that and they didn't
swing very well
and it's one of the things that people
remember to this day and that was like
about his accident to come back and he
won the u.s open right and
you know me playing in the pro-ams and
me
kind of well i used to be in that world
of gone from
not so much anymore i love golf but uh
i don't go where they don't want me and
you think i know man i try to do so much
to help that game
and you i know that
if it doesn't work that'll be something
that
will be will carry on forever but then
you know i told people like i read this
movie
that i might be doing with almost about
you know this book walking with urban
and they say well
what part of you i said what i would i
would think i'd be the golfer i think
right
why would i be the caddy i didn't think
i would be the caddy
right and um when
you know when i saw that eddie was the
golfer i can't believe how
hard he worked oh fantastic right and
how
good he became at being a golfer
or resembling a golfer and hitting his
own shots and making it his own putts
the people that i showed the trailer to
the you know this is a 20-footer with a
slight break to the left and
he makes it yeah and getting
and getting terry gannon who was pumping
it during the la open
pumping the movie during the broadcast
and faraday which are two
two huge names massive yeah uh who are
on tv in the world of golf
every week that that was the credibility
of that and quinones is in it
is is really really good
and you know golfers or at least before
they were very
faith-based type guys you know i saw
bubba watson at
lakeside you know we went out to him i
think i gave the script to his wife i'm
not sure that she even
read it but this would have been a great
opportunity for
somebody in golf to step up and to have
played what billy did but then
nobody would have done it as good as
billy like you want to you want to tell
how you found billy
yeah yeah so billy was uh billy billy
his name his full name
billy boyd yeah so billy boyd from lord
of the rings plays pippin
right yep uh you know we're we're
writing uh ross and
mark are writing the script and one
thing we realized in the script is
we're playing in the world entire right
and everybody all the characters are
american
right that that would never happen you'd
have people from all over the world in
the world entire
and billy had been a friend of mine for
a very long time
and uh we had talked about him doing it
and mark met off and ross said let's
let's
change the character from american and
let's create a scottish character
specifically for billy
they wrote wrote the part for him
rewrote the script
and then i sent it to billy and billy
was like yeah i'm in it
that's how it came together yeah he he
billy loved
the part that was the thing is he felt
it was such
a person who had struggles that was
perceived as
kind of a bad guy right but was really a
good guy
underneath it all and just needed
someone to see that and he loved it well
you know in the world of golf
you know they used to say that
so and so was the best player to never
win a major
because in in golf it all comes down to
winning
i don't think you could be the most
winning golfer
on the pga tour and not collect majors
along the way like anaconda corvo
never won it's very difficult to win and
there are some european players you know
darren clark won a british open
but right now you see in these last
tournaments were in the middle of march
that lee westwood
has resurfaced as a as a golfer he
didn't win the pga
the players championship second second
yeah
so his career is one where
he's been right up against it and not
been able to
get past you know that last day right
and he lost the um
arnold palmer on a putt that he left
short that's for a guy that's a
world-class player
you never do and then he lost the
players championship came in second
but they don't announce that anymore on
golf because the players went to the
commissioner and said
you know every time they say we're the
best player who's never won a major
it puts undue pressure on us so please
if you could stop saying that and they
did they stopped
because those guys couldn't it's just
when
when somebody's talking about you that
you can't hear but millions of people at
home can hear
they say oh you know he's had five
second place finishes he's never won a
major
and they eliminated that part of golf
that's how
that's how difficult golf is but also
um trevor emelman is a is a very close
friend of mine he won
he won the masters in 2008 uh
and he's very very religious so i would
love for him to be able to you know
get a link to see this at his house i'm
surprised we didn't go to him he would
have been great well we did you gave me
his phone number
yeah and we had talked to him but what
was going on is he was doing something
in south africa at the time we were
filming but yeah we did go to him
yeah okay and george you talk about um
uh you know great golf movies
and you think about billy boyd's caddy
in the movie you know
yes oh yeah so billy oh great billy boyd
so it's me and edward olmos and edward's
joe
uh amabliamo and then i'm herb
and then billy boyd is um archie
archie what a great name archie archie
borthwick
and his caddy is ross wiley
riley daniels and wylie daniels is
played by brian
christopher mcdonald who is known as
shooter mcgavin to the rest of us
awesome yeah
isn't that great incredible so those
scenes with billy
and uh christopher myself and eddie
there
on the back were walking down the
fairway really really good
and um the burning but
somebody wanted is it giving away too
much the burning bush uh
no i think the real the real twist is is
the end
pot which we don't want to give that
away um
the last part of the 18th hole well i
mean
yeah in a lot of movies unfortunately
you can kind of see things
you know coming um toward the end you're
like how is this
not going to be that this is nobody
expects
what happens at the end right and
there's
and there's two endings in this movie
there's an ending on the golf course
and then there's an ending later at the
bus right
that's right yeah so time i remember
when we when we were shooting that bus
scene
you were george was really emotional you
you were
really emotional and we were shooting
the coverage
you know when every time you shoot a
movie you obviously do multiple angles
and multiple takes
and i was shooting eddie first and you
were so emotional you were crying you
were crying on on eddie's coverage which
is
never happens an actor never actually
brings it when they're not on camera
so eddie pulls me to the side he said
you got to shoot george right now you
got to shoot george right now you got
you know
so we changed the the lineup of how
we're going to shoot things we turned
around
and we grabbed george and and you were
it wasn't acting
you were not acting you were really
emotional
saying goodbye to to eddie's character
and to kathleen and
and what the journey had meant to you
and eddie
afterwards said to me said that was the
right thing he said i've never seen an
actor
so into the moment and so believable as
what george just did he said that was
incredible
yeah but everybody was crying on that
that's the thing is george didn't even
realize this everybody behind the camera
because of the emotion that you had in
your face
every all of us were in tears because of
what you were doing with the character
it was so real right everybody was just
like fanning their faces it was
it was a pretty intense moment and it
wasn't written to
uh for emotion really if you think about
herb as a character he's gone he's you
know
a thousand years old he's been sent to
different people
um and the reason i look like the way i
look is because
it's in new mexico or vegas or wherever
and it has to look
close enough to the that was a great
answer close enough to the people who
are
in that area that he does not look like
he doesn't belong
right so that he fits in with you know
fits seamlessly into
this community exactly to where you
can't tell who's who and i believe that
that's
you know really kind of part of what
happens in people's lives when
maybe they're saved by getting hit by a
car or maybe
they uh are alerted to something by
someone and there's no way that that
could have been done
other than somebody who is not in human
form
that's taking on the the human form
right
which i which i highly i highly believe
and we talked about that on uh the
podcast
before and last night in the middle of
my hallway a flash
of light goes on and just one time and
that means that somebody's trying to
somebody's trying to appear so um
what are we expecting from this movie
because i already i know that
you know you're looking for distribution
but then also
i don't think i've been in a film that
is global i mean maybe you know smurfs
but
real but not as a human
as a canine marmaduke marmaduke is
the little girl this little girl i saw
in the desert she's five years old and
and
you know they're like say hello to
george and she's kind of shy you know
she's kind of shy
i said uh what's your favorite movie oh
she goes she loves real
i said i'm the i'm the bird in real
and she looks at me and i said i put it
on youtube
and then i said flying isn't what you
believe in here it's what you believe
in here and then i played the clip and
she
totally you know believed it yeah
but what are we expecting of this
because it the release of it is going to
be
yeah yeah it is it is so so we got very
lucky so interestingly enough you know
we were talking about going to these
studios and
we talked about pure flicks who early on
said you know we don't we don't we don't
know if this movie's for us and they
landed being the international
distributor
right we finished the movie they love it
they're like this is the best movie
we've ever seen
george you were there when we held that
sales screening you put it together
right at uta and they immediately after
they saw
their head comes over i love it we want
the movie we want to
do it internationally so big stuff i
mean we're doing
our usa release right april 30th
may 1st and may 3rd we're launching with
a special event through fathom
right so just launching kicking off
there
and then universal is going to handle
all the home entertainment stuff
once we're done so we've got you know we
already sold
the whole film to latin america and
europe so
what do we expect out of this to be
honest i think it's going to be a movie
that we all i mean look let's let me
back up a second and say
when we were on set let's be honest it
was a magical fun experience we all came
together
close friends hanging out brian came to
visit us right we had a blast
that good fortune and good
friendships that we that we made on that
film
honestly i think is going to translate
to the world because it means something
right really i have to give a plug and
and this
this you'll appreciate this george so
when when we
were casting i was very blessed as a
young director gary marshall
god rest his soul took me under his wing
he had a script he called me up he said
hey i was going to direct this script i
want you to direct it i'm going to
produce it i'm going to act in it a film
called the twilight of the golds
and gary really mentored me and he
taught me so much as a director
and one of the things he told me was you
know making a movie so difficult you
only want to work with people that are
good people
that that you'd like to be around and i
saw george had made a movie with gary
and i knew gary only worked with the
very best so i said if
george can work with gary then i can i
can definitely work with george
and gary you'll appreciate this story
george if i haven't told you the story
so i was a 28 year old director i had
won an award at sundance and i'm doing
this movie with the great gary marshall
and he calls me the night before the
shoot he says
you know i need to talk to you we're
shooting tomorrow i need to talk to you
so i drive to his house into luca lake
i go to the door his wife barbara
answers the
door says gary's waiting for you he's in
the bedroom and
yeah this is like the scene going to see
you know the godfather with brando in
the in the chair getting the cat
so i go to see gary and uh in his
bedroom
and he says tomorrow is your big day
we're
shooting the movie well done i said
that's great i said yes he goes
do you have your shoplifts i said yeah i
got my shot let's go do you have your
storyboards i said with their story and
says okay
now i'm going to tell you the most
important thing you can learn about
directing a movie
directing a movie is like hosting a
party
everybody needs to have a good time and
if they have a good time
it'll be there on the screen if they
have a shitty time it's going to be a
shitty movie
so go host a great party make sure
everyone has a good time and the movie
will be great eat that
that was his that was his directing
advice i think that director
is the host of a party i think in this
podcast whenever
someone is going to say something that
is extremely profound
that it should be uh separated by either
a sound
or some bells or an alert that tells
people that
what you're going to hear ross say
is going to be something that if you
adhere to it
will change the way you look at projects
or life
right grant
you know what i mean and then later on
my [ __ ] baptism
so so i i agree i agree with
i agree with that because i walked
from my house to the falcon theater
where's gary's theater and they said you
know gary wants you
to look at this movie and
you know i was i was on tv you know then
and
uh i i said oh i'll walk over there
[ __ ] huge mistake
you know ladies stop me everybody that
was in line at ellen that was going to
get coffee all there everybody at bob's
big boy somebody from across the street
and he's like i heard this noise outside
i said what
is going on outside is george talking to
all the ladies from
ellen and um i love that guy
and toward the end of his life we got to
atlanta remember that and the phone rang
in my room
and i never answered i answered it and
it's
it's he says george it's gary i'm i know
that you just got to the hotel
i just only want to tell you that i love
you
and i said no no i'm coming down no i'm
on the way out but i just only wanted to
say
that i knew you were here and i'm
calling you to tell you that i love you
wow
and nobody does that great person he
he was the most gracious kind
giving human being i've ever met in my
life and he
he had this thing remember he had his
assistant that ran his life
and he always brought him his tuna
sandwiches oh the other great thing that
gary said to me we were shooting this is
the other two great things gary
great piece of advice we're shooting the
movie and he hands me
a uh silver uh vial
a silver vial it was a particularly
stressful scene i was directing it
and it's and i said what is this open it
up and i open it up and inside are
toothpicks
he said much better than cigarettes
start chewing on toothpicks
right and he got in and if you remember
gary was always chewing on toothpicks
you know what i'm going to agree to that
and then he hit hooked on tooth and then
when somebody said to me
in an interview how would you
describe somebody to gary on the set so
that they would find them
i said look for the guy who's eating
half a sandwich and has a coffee cup
that styrofoam full of peanuts
and uh they walk 10 feet and he goes
george and gary held his up he had a
sandwich and he had
peanuts in the classic um
why should people watch this film
walking with her
well it's you know we're coming out of a
really dark time the pandemic has
really kept us all down emotionally and
mentally and it's been very very
difficult
this is an uplifting inspirational film
a friend of mine
a very close friend saw the film
and he said this is like it's a
wonderful life he said this is the
most feel-good film i have seen said
it's a wonderful life and he said let me
tell you something
no matter what happens it's 111 minutes
he said no matter what happens the first
hundred minutes of the film it doesn't
matter because the last 15 are so great
and so feel good
audiences are going to walk out of this
theater feeling great
he said i he said i haven't felt this
good watching movies since it's a
wonderful life so
i think it's such an upbeat
inspirational feel-good movie
that it's going to really elevate
people's moods coming out of a dark
time well we've never seen a time like
this
in all of our lives and it's unfortunate
that you know
we all know people who who have lost
their lives to this virus and uh
you know we all have to carry on and
whether you're faith
based or not we're not going to succeed
or carry on without
believing in something either each other
or whatever you consider your higher
power so
um i i can't wait for people to
see me um like this in this movie
you know because it's something that
i've never done and i was i was
that was telling somebody i was telling
the
the people that i was with the poster i
said you know poster's a bit
intimidating for me because
it says academy award nominee edward
james olmos academy award
nominee uh um kathleen quinlan and over
my name nothing you could have put
[ __ ] rescues dogs like an alba award
winner
three-time a mocking a winner you know i
wanted a local
emmy brewmaster i want to a local emmy
which is
you know not embarrassing that is nine
times smaller than the real i mean
that's awesome [ __ ] [ __ ] keychain
hey don't forget you you had approval
over that poster
we could have put we could buy anything
you want we can go back any printed yet
it's only it's all it's only digital
it's cool man no it's good i mean
i mean um you know kathleen quinlan
um is you know there was a there was
another actress
let's let's talk for a second about how
you know you can think you could have
someone who's equally that was
another i believe it was an academy
award winner
that was in there which did she win um
mary mcdonald
two-time nominee two-time nominee yeah
and she also um
an amazing actress and
i don't know why we lost her but she did
text me and say you know i'm sorry that
this
didn't work out i was looking forward to
working with you which i thought was
is very classy of someone you know but
it's equivalent to like somebody writing
a thank you card
yeah she was wonderful she really was it
just i think it was
creatively it didn't work out you know
she she really had an idea of where she
wanted the character to go that we were
open with
um but um at the end i think it just
didn't jive but she's amazing she's
wonderful
yeah um how different do you think the
character would have changed if she had
done it
dramatically let me let me let me ask
you a question
how do you think when we were shooting
the golf scenes and it was about 30
degrees out and we did that for about 10
11 days
and kathleen quinlan had no lines but
she's standing there
in a short sleeved shirt because we're
trying to pretend that it's 80 degrees
and she has no lines she's just standing
there in the crowd
nodding and smiling and you know not for
11 days she does this
not many actresses would do that in the
30 degree weather stand there with no
lines for 11 days
and every day be more cheerful than the
next so we were very blessed to have
kathleen quinlan she was a
real not only a great actress and is
amazing in the movie but a real team
player
and just wanted this movie to be
successful every day that she was on the
set
who would have done a better job than me
as herb
nobody no i mean it nobody there there
wasn't anybody
truly maybe peter dinklage
oh peter boyle
you know it's um you know i think i
think in the
i think in the end you know
when i first met edward almost you could
say it's almost
a bit of a recreation of real life i met
edward james alma
at the imachan awards at the beverly
wilshire in 1988 and there i met cesar
romero i met
milton berle i met a lot of people that
are not around but then also people that
became my my friends you know and
eddie you know didn't have to say you
know come to my house let's you know
have lunch and you know
i want to get to know you a little bit
and
i went to his house and i remember he
had a porsche back there that he got
at a police auction from a drug dealer
in one miami vice
when they sell drug dealers uh cars and
stuff this great black porsche with a
big fin in the back
crazy um i would have had a dog sniff it
before i would have taken con
uh parts that i'm sure one of those
bumpers had coke in it
the the and after that we stayed
very close we maybe bumped heads a
little bit
you know during those 30 years but um
he didn't he did my almost like second
to last episode
of my uh television show he directed it
uh directed and he was in it and
uh that was the end of the kind of the
that
120 episode run but
a long since then we've you know come to
uh highly respect each other i think
what you
which you notice in the in the way we
were away from the
away from the scenes and stuff like that
but at that emotion which
is a break of character i think if you
look at herb he probably would not have
had
emotion because it's something that he
had done for years for
hundreds of years as a messenger you
don't think he's going to get emotional
because it's just a
it was just a gig and kind of in the way
he says it it's
i've done this before uh many many times
and i you know it adds to
what's beautiful about the movie is that
even somebody who
was a messenger who's kind of maybe
trapped between you know when people
pass they may not
get there sometimes they're in that kind
of limbo
uh and they have to prove themselves
before they get to move on which
i sense a lot in my house and um
the spontaneous emotion of him saying
is this it you know will i ever see you
again
is uh is what got me man
it just but you know
i learned so much in that month of
rehearsal as well like
that's edward almost as a guy that just
doesn't show up to work
and hasn't done his work he made me do
the work
when we were in there remember guys we'd
be there all afternoon
rehearsing and yeah i don't want to do
that i don't want to stand up and
do scenes or try to get those words out
and i i think maybe it was maybe the
second day
he said oh george's george is going to
get a nomination for this like he's
going to be really good at this
like you guys always said remember we
were rehearsing in manhattan beach
that scene where you reveal yourself
as god you take off your glasses and and
it's funny because
that scene's so powerful because we you
you chose to wear sunglasses throughout
the golf tournament yeah
which initially i said well wait a
second we can't see his eyes and then i
said to myself well
that's the point that's the point he's
not human you can't see his eyes
right that that makes him less
accessible to the audience so when you
lower your sunglasses and you say
he's he basically says i i i need
got and you say i'm here and you just
look at me take off your sunglasses
say i'm here well when we did that in
rehearsals you said to eddie you said
i'm here and eddie stops he goes holy
[ __ ] i just got chills he's god
that's what this whole movie is about he
is
god georgie is god that's what this is
and we all got
chills at that moment on the on the uh
when we were rehearsing and of course as
a director you're always worried
[ __ ] did i just blow it because we did
it rehearsal and it won't be there on
the set
yeah well i got a job i got chills ross
on that note i'm starting cutting you
off but
i got chills when we have to take out
all
the costs to take out all the
reflections in georgia's sunglasses and
posts
that gave me the chills producer that's
where brian got his kills
how much how much would this one do no
ma'am for the reflection
but it came out great it came out great
sorry i cut you off but i had to i had
to say that
but if you don't mind me and then on the
set um when we're there george has that
moment and it's in the film where
where he takes off his glasses and he
says just simply two words to eddie's
character he says
i'm here and the camera pushes in on him
and the camera pushes on eddie and
eddie's jaw drops
with the realization that he is in the
presence of
what when the movie we refer to as al
the almighty lord
and uh it's it's it's a chilling moment
in the movie it was chilling in
rehearsals and it's
it to this day is how many times i've
seen it still gets me let me say
let me let me say that i think this
applies
whether you see well we all hope that
you see the movie but what i learned
from this movie
can apply to can apply to everybody
um here's a guy that had lost his belief
in life because a few very important
uh family members had passed and
he was extremely negative and when you
lose your faith
whether you don't even have to come from
a religious background but when you've
given up
on yourself you've given up on the
people that are around you
right and um
and not particularly in in this movie
but whenever things
are going good for someone or whenever
something good happens
when you're when you're not grounded
in something you can tend to
mistrust it or not respected or not
believe it or not
or not show up to it and um
anybody that listens to this whenever
you listen to it you know
if you have a friend that's that's been
that way call them out on it
and explain to them the examples of
you know here's when something could
have gone good you didn't go you didn't
try you didn't go you made an excuse why
you couldn't go
now your car wouldn't start but it's all
[ __ ] you know you always you're just
trying
not to go but when you don't go
you never know what's gonna happen and
when you do go
whether it's good or bad you at least
had an option
when i when i got back from san
francisco in the
uh late 90s i always got back hungover
you know from
from coming back from san francisco and
i was living in sherman oaks and when i
was married
and anne's like tomorrow they want you
to go to um
santa monica to to just meet this
director ken loesch
and i said [ __ ] that i ain't going and
she's like why not it's just a meeting
i'm not going for like that and he goes
well so what am i gonna tell you you're
not gonna go you're just a media you
don't have to read anything
so i said i'm not going to go then i
went into a room and i thought
of not going and then i knew what was
good for me i said i'm going to go
and i went to santa monica and i met ken
lowe's
brilliant director won the palm duo yeah
um
like khan many many times and
he wanted me to read uh improv scene
with this guy greg montgomery who was a
police officer
he also was in the movie and he said and
i remember you
don't don't you're don't no you're
giving him no
quarter which i didn't understand i
don't know what no quarter meant
uh but i think it means like to be tough
on him so i was a boss and he was late
and i you know i got into him in the
beginning but he was a big police
officer and he kind of got into me at
the end and we were like almost face to
face and here's this british guy going
well
well yes yes yes great great great
you know like separates us great so then
he come
he comes and that was a bread and roses
and then i go and read and i remember
and i remember
cheech saying this to me and this
applies as well in life
he because i just couldn't get anything
to happen
you know um and i would always call him
for
you know not advice but just you know
like uplifting things you know right and
he says you know all you have to do is
get that one thing
and that one thing will get you other
things but the hardest thing to do is to
get that one thing
but don't give up because you'll you'll
get it
and then when i went in there this girl
um
the last scene i did was she was
always late and her kid was always sick
and they had a desk there and they had
my desk and they had a chair where she
was going to sit in
and i decided to stand up and look out
the window instead of
being seated when she walked in and i
hadn't acted i'd [ __ ] done ski patrol
10 years before
[Laughter]
and i didn't know that i remember
looking out the window and i could hear
her
kind of coming in and she said
you wanted to see me and i'm looking out
the window and i said sit your
ass down without turning
and then i said if i turn around and
she's sitting down
i got this part yep because you know you
say sit your ass
down and if she's standing by the chair
going [ __ ] you i'm not gonna sit down
and when i turned around she was sitting
down and um
i did it again and and i remember
uh they said oh we'll see you and then i
was in the car
and i got a call and the guy said hey
congratulations and i called chi-chi and
i said i got it man
that's amazing i got the one thing and
it changed everything
what was the movie again bread and roses
it's about the generous strike in los
angeles
oh wow wow and adrian brody was in it he
just won the academy award
and uh it was it was it was really good
and of course like a stupid ass i leave
because i'm doing the ice house on
saturday and he's like i wish you
wouldn't go man
i have one thing for you to do like and
i and the end of the movie my character
wasn't resolved because
i had to leave and that's how it bothers
me because it was a great result to the
movie
but you know i've never been faith-based
but i believe in karma i believe in
you know moving on forward and i believe
in being good to people
and uh did you want to ask something uh
yeah i wanted to ask you guys what it
was like to work with george because you
never had worked with george before
correct
no neither it was the first time so did
anything about
him on the set in front of cameras or
behind the camera surprise you at all
yes yeah definitely yeah definitely so
you know
with uh having not worked with the
person and you see the films that you do
and watching your comedy routines you
know you tend to have an idea of like oh
i think that how this person is going to
be
and um it was a little intimidating to
be honest with that first time we met
you because we didn't know how it was
going to
how it was going to unfold but um at the
end of the
day you know you weren't just that guy
telling jokes all day long
you were you were there very you were
very present
you were there for your role you were
like i i've got to get these lines down
it was so serious and then once we got
off the set
then we were just normal people having a
good time having a drink right
but it was it was very different because
i was i was so
surprised at how grounded you were
because when you take a comedian
you think a lot of improv but you were
so
into bringing that character to life and
that's why
quite frankly you know when we said this
is this is
some this is a character that nobody's
ever seen you in because you're so
president and present in creating
something
right right yeah yeah i remember
almost the the first scene we were
working on
you turned to me and you said is it okay
if i
adlin if i improv and i said well
you know i cast you because i want you
to do exactly that
you know if you feel aligned if you want
to say something do something i'm as you
know george i'm very actor-centric
i started out as an actor and i believe
all good films start with great
performances
and once you were free to
explore this character inside and out i
felt like you really took off and some
of the best lines in the movie
are lines that that you came up with you
know you came up with some
great great lines um and unfortunately
we couldn't put them all in
right uh but you you were also very
respectful of the material
you know again mark met off an academy
award-winning screenwriter a playwright
um you know you were very respectful of
the lines and and really worked very
very hard
to get the material but you know i
almost from that time you nailed on here
and rehearsal
in manhattan beach when you said that
instantly
you were that guy you know and then and
all actors talk about it lawrence
olivier said he always found the walk
the way the character walked so to get
into character
he would walk a certain way to sat in
character as that character
so for me that line i'm here that made
you
heard and so whether you consciously or
unconsciously or subconsciously kind of
went to that place
when the camera rolled and we said
action you were extremely reverential
about the material and extremely
reverential about working with eddie and
kathleen
but you you became that guy and like you
said it's interesting to go back to that
that last moment
when you cried it was breaking character
it was not what i had imagined that
final scene would be
you're wearing a certain outfit that um
suggests you're
you're being transported to literally an
entirely another country you're going to
see one of the worst people in the world
and be his messenger
and his touchstone um but it worked it
was a happy gift
you know the crying because when you
first did i said gee i don't know if he
would break down
but it was it was so strong i said you
know let's just go with it and see and
of course
it it just really is this incredible
uh you know bookend to the film what i
love about that
and it also like you said it shows that
this mission herbs had thousands of
missions
this one was special what i loved about
uh you know ross as a director and you
know spontaneously
um crying over a very emotional
uh part of the movie the end of the
movie he comes over to me
goes less cry less
that's awesome yeah well you know the
question too much
the heating of the chest is too much
just cry less you know
the jerking you still got to get the
words out don't don't you know yeah
uh but then you have an option with me
completely in tears and then one less
and you guys were so i i got a great
opportunity to hang out on the set with
you guys a couple times and you're all
right
ridiculously close i mean everybody
seemed like a family there is that do
you think
obviously the people involved but you
think it's because of maybe the type of
film a faith-based film because it was
it was so kumbaya everybody loved
hanging out with each other
it was it was so so crazy tight
everybody was very family
yeah i think it was i think it was i
think when you
when you go into a film like that um
i think everyone kind of has a
perception like i think that everybody
involved is probably right off the bat a
good person yeah and that's just my
perception of it yeah
and when you when we you go in thinking
like that you're like i want to be on my
best behavior
because what the film represents and i
want to think about
how other people would feel i want to be
really open-minded to everybody
to their requests to their needs and i
think yes that probably was
a binder for it right but then
you get to know everybody and you're
just like i'm having a good time with
this person
and and i have a huge respect for these
people and people that you just and even
um mj grant you know who was the asl
um uh interpreter for uh for tammy
santameyer um
you know just the way she blended in and
working with everybody
as the asl was amazing to have her there
like from the ground up right from
anybody in the crew
cast production everyone just got along
fantastic and i think it was because of
the the movie
but then the people ended up being good
too yeah i mean it was the
the best thing george about this movie
and is eddie i don't know if you read it
eddie in an interview
said this was the best experience he's
ever had making a movie
this is a guy who's made 80 movies
unbelievable so
when i when i read that line i hope i
hope millions and millions of people see
the film i hope it's a big hit
financially and otherwise
but eddie's saying it's the best
experience he ever had making a movie to
me
that was you know that that was enough
but i i
the real reason again i i said it the
credit for
that set being as as as loving
and as family oriented really i've got i
just have to give to the late gary
marshall because
that was that was his thing and he
really you know
he didn't care when i you know what what
the camera was doing he didn't care
about the lighting he cared that
everybody on that set
was having a good time and and pulling
in the same direction and we were
really fortunate that we we had that
well i mean how beautiful is it that i
got to work with him
and that he meant so much to me and i
didn't know that until right now but
you and i got along incredibly well you
and i
as well and you know kathleen and i are
still
friends eddie's still friends she came
to see us in portland
yeah and um you know we honor mark man i
mean you know
that guy uh you know to go you know ross
to go to the set
those days and to be to be able to see
these
an agnostic even who found something at
the end of his life
as well you know very much so yeah
and by the way when you were you know
something i wanted to mention
you know you haven't talked about yet
but you you were doing your stand-up
all over on tour on the weekend so you
were what was interesting to me is how
you know and you'd show up with brian
because he was on tour with you yeah and
he and he'd pop up and even momo
would show up too right but how that's a
question i always had for you like
you know how did you do it really
because you you were
busting your ass all week long in
character is herb
and then you take a flight out late
you'd leave for the weekend
you'd go do your your shows and then
you'd show right back at 5 00 am ready
ready
ready to work and it was like you you
didn't sleep how did you balance that
well you know you i already have the
stuff kind of in my head you know i
transcribe all the shows
and the one of the reasons why i always
wear a suit
almost like a you know a baseball player
that gets to the
ballpark at like three to do extra
batting practice you know one
when either it's friday or saturday
but by three o'clock i'm in the room
trying to sleep from three to six
so if i sleep from three to five thirty
or three by three
nobody's gonna see me from three really
kind of before the show
and um i take that nap and when i get up
i take a shower and i know that while
i'm in the shower and when i get out
i transform to the guy that's gonna wear
the suit so when i put the suit on
it uh it tells me that i'm
in that of that mindset and that i'm
gonna go out there and not be anything
other than
the guy that you know you the all these
people paid to see so
it's it's a process as well that's f
it's funny
last week george i was playing golf with
greg nye
and i just want to say i shot a 78 first
time i broke 80. well done very exciting
well uh let's say something about joe
bullock he said to me that time we
played golf that
and i never heard anybody say this about
their father
but their father was a happy guy
and just like what can i do guys to make
your day great
and i mean you know he teared up
and i'm like wait a minute wait a minute
tell me again he's like my dad was like
our best friend
and ev we lost our mother so we don't
have a mother and
he just was more than a mother and
father just became this incredible
person that they still revere you know
when most people talk about their
parents they don't have much to say
and um i found that guy
incredible also i found him a bit
of a uh he can be a herb as well
somebody that
is on this earth for a purpose yeah very
much yeah
joe is hurt right yeah joe's a real life
he really is
you know and very supportive and very
happy and really funny
and you know he loves golf we're out
there all playing
and um what do you want to say about him
no i mean joe's the greatest ross you
don't you go first joe
literally is is is the that i said
uh you i don't think you were there
george we screened it for the investors
in las cruces and i got up and i said
listen
the only thing i want after this movie's
over is for joe bullock to come up to me
and said i'm proud of you you did a good
job i said if that happened
i don't care if we make a dollar if joe
is happy
and he's proud of this film that's all
that matters to me
and and he did he came up to me he said
i'm proud of you
you made it great and really as and and
the films dedicated to mark but joe
is you know he wrote the novel he raised
the money
he he was so supportive at every turn
and he you know you have that expression
they'd give you the shirt off their back
i don't think there's a person on this
planet good
or bad that joe wouldn't give the shirt
off his back he's the most gracious
giving human being
he's a saint and they really truly is
the same yeah
and we also you know we also want to
thank
a couple of people that are very
companies that are very close to me
you know we thank the guys uh terry
again and uh
david ferrity and nbc and the golf
channel
all great but titleist and pxg
came through really big at a time when
you know
they kind of come golf companies that
kind of really are not doing that you
know ross they weren't they're not
giving you money for the banner and
giving you money for
the clubs and for the uh
signs and um they went above and beyond
what i
what i thought they would do and i'm
very very proud that
companies that i have a history with
would not have forgotten
me when it's something that i rarely do
is go to them for something for
not just me but for the for this
wonderful film yeah i know they
also also pat monahan george
you got gotta gotta thank him i mean
yeah i think pat you know pat's one of
the best
and when i and when i sent pat the
script
in his family there there was someone
who suffered
a very tough loss and him reading that
script
when it just just i believe happened was
it's funny man it's it's like a sign for
him he read it he was in tears his wife
was in tears
and he said you know i'm in because
this happened in my family and reading
this
i almost couldn't believe that i was
reading these pages because
it was so similar to what a family
member was going through suffering
a devastating loss that's sad so he
he gave us um
what is that song called calling all
angels calling all angels and did he
write one
yeah a new one he wrote an original song
he wrote recorded an original song for
us
changed my mind you know that was his
beautiful amazing original song for the
film that
we're going to promote heavily but it's
like it's you've heard it
it's from it's from the heart like when
he wrote that song
you could tell he read the script
hit him in the soul right and then he
put it right out from where he was
speaking from his heart it was beautiful
you cry
you know yeah and it makes the movie and
and for people that don't know pat
monahan by the way is the lead singer of
the band train
and the way that we know each other when
i was doing my talk show
they did hey soul sister which they were
incredible
and then afterwards he and i talked and
we stayed friends and then we did this
thing in san francisco and we stayed
friends there and he
is maybe has the greatest laugh
we met some dudes had some great laughs
he's he's animated too
and he rubs his hands like a fly when
he's really enjoying himself
he does that and he can't believe it and
he'll have george tell him a joke and
100 of the time
and one time this caddy came to and he
was like five two and i said where's the
where's the other half of you
that was stop laughing a little bit i
said
well i'm giving you i'm giving you half
of your feet because i only got half a
guy
yeah but we also got you know you know
we had we to be honest this movie came
together
so great like you you brought so many
great friends and relationships to the
movie that
were a dream and we can't even forget
like we're talking about
you know pat and doing this song and all
this great stuff but we were also so
lucky to get uh you know henry and ringo
garza
from those lonely boys and they let us
use heaven
you know they let us use heaven in it
right and it was amazing i remember
reaching out i could not get a hold of
them
and sony was giving me some issues about
getting the song
for usage and you said i i know these
guys
and so i went to instagram and i just
instagrammed uh ringo directly i didn't
think he was gonna
reach out to me and he reached out right
away and i said hey
uh george and i would love to ask for
you to use
heaven and he said oh my god here's my
number and we called them yeah right
yeah and just like that let us use the
song i mean that
you know in itself is uh all of those
i've met those only boys on the talk
show i don't see them all the time but
you know they call me like theo george
so you were there in the beginning and
and um it's amazing you know i was never
one
to um have been considered
reliable or good friend you know brian
brian is somebody that
i had a guy that was opening for me in
the early 2000s and
he you know was kind of complaining
about things and
things were going really well and there
were he was complaining about things
that
would have given him more but he already
had enough like enough wasn't enough
and then i said well this guy's gotta
this guy's gotta go
and i thought uh well who would i want
to be around
that i like it's pretty short list and
then we met
in san francisco and we worked together
in sacramento and i said
hey man uh you know i like you we should
work together i didn't even have his
number and i called the punch line in
san francisco i got his number and i
called him and i left this message
hey brian it's george lopez call me back
i'll change your life that's exactly
what he said
and i haven't yet but i i promise no no
i get to hang out with you guys
uh so yeah so he and i you know all of
us here and
and ross and everybody beautiful man
yeah it is
it is i have one last question i hope
you guys don't mind who came up with uh
herb's wardrobe
because it's a little bit of everything
i mean how did that come about
i think that was ross and mark met off
in the script
and then you know really i think it was
if i recall crew it was very clear
how the wardrobe was yeah we wanted mark
and i would
we were creating the screenplay wanted
herb to be
a esoteric eccentric unusual guy
riding a motorcycle just not what you
would uh
picture god's messenger to be like at
all
right yeah um completely completely
against type and like george said it's
really interesting that he said that
because i think we we didn't talk much
about this but the idea like george said
is that herb
had had a difficult past
and that god said to him hey i could i
could send you
to hell for what you've done i could you
know but instead i'm going to send you
to earth
and i want you to earn your wings so to
speak
you know for you to go and ascend to
heaven
and and george very much got that
instinctively and that was the character
we tried to create we didn't want this
uh character like michael landon and
what was that show
uh at a lot um what was that show that
they played the angel
touched by a character heaven i think
was called touched by a cartwright
mark and i come up with the wardrobe and
and george and greg lavoie are fabulous
regular boys
the best they made that possible so yeah
no you got to give a huge shout out to
greg because he did well
but also when you ask who who uh who
created the wardrobe
right i mean there was a lot of people
from the script to greg
and then george i remember george i am
wearing that oh yeah
right i ain't wearing that and then he
got to choose create herb from that
aspect too
yeah but you know some of those those
pants you said said i look like a rodeo
clown
i totally look like a [ __ ] rodeo it
looks so great though it's like
everything i keep those pants because i
would [ __ ] wear them
it's delicious i can't help it am i
allowed to drink this now like oh
man i've been drinking it i'm like i'm
supposed to drink the producer who did
this little sip thing to me earlier and
i go what
was that [ __ ] yeah no i i i spilled it
all the way down
oh he was he was telling me to drink i
thought you were telling me something
don't drink when you talk
that dude's got no respect it's
delicious it's really good
and it might hit you a little hard too
so be careful i forgot we have to go
live with the ig but
how many percent alcohol is this thing
five no it's like four
four four point four yeah yeah yeah but
there's more because i told you but
there's a plankton there so it's a full
pint
so that'll do it it's great beer by the
way great beer
i love the artwork by the way ross i
wish you could have one with us that'd
be nice yeah
gravy hibiscus lager
hey ross you don't drink do you oh yeah
of course only drinks beer
oh man it would be cool if you find
yourself i don't i don't care
i don't drink wine we're gonna we're
gonna send you uh
ross we're gonna send you some of this
george lopez brewing company i think i
think you'll love it yeah
i would love it hey i gotta i gotta call
you you and brian
since i have you both i got a call this
morning guy leaves me a
message on my phone says this is so and
so
from texas give me a call and so i call
him back he says hey i'm uh
i'm a minister in texas and i saw the
trailer of your movie
uh and i love it he said this is amazing
i've been showing it to my congregation
they're they're so excited
and i'm part of a group of 200 other
churches and i sent it to all the 200
other
uh ministers and they all love it and
they're all excited he said so i think
it's been seen
over 500 000 times alone just off of me
sending it to the 200 ministers and
their
congregants and me and my congregants he
said man he said you don't realize how
big this movie is going to be and how
many lives it's going to change
you know what i think that
i think that that's something that um
is unexpected it would have been
expected if this
had been stayed as i mean on the nose
faith-based which eddie didn't want to
do that remember eddie was like
adjusting it
right but to get that call knowing that
we universally made it uh appeal to
everyone but also
that somebody like that would feel like
you know it belongs to them
is a testament to both of you guys yeah
no all of us
we're on ig live right now these people
i don't think they can hear us but
um we're gonna we're gonna get rid of
you guys for a second and then we're
gonna go down with them
all right guys i i uh
thank you for doing this and it means a
lot to see you guys and
here to her to her and to everybody
involved i know ross thank you ross
virtual cheers i say hello to your
daughter who as well
is is really great in the movie yeah we
had a a chance to talk to her
everybody in the movie had somebody
significant except me there by myself
that's not true man my mom came just to
see you
now you tell me choking a guy in hooters
all right
i remember kathleen came in the trailer
the police want to talk to you i was all
calm she's like
you're not freaking out i go please want
to talk to her
if they didn't want to talk to me but uh
yeah that all worked out as well thank
you very much for you know for getting
me a lawyer in you
in uh oh my god the two top attorneys
uh you know in in the state of new
mexico representing
oh that's awesome awesome never had a
chance i remember when that happened you
were
i turned to rdad i said all right what's
going on we're not shooting he says oh
we've got a little problem with george i
said what's going on
he says i'll tell you later i said no
tell me what's going on he says well the
cops are with george in his trailer
what and you know that guy played that
game man he played
good cop bad cop he was pretending to be
my friend
and he wasn't and that's
he kind of he kind of got me uh but
you know the lawyer said hey man that
guy he was trying to play you he's
trying to get you to admit to something
that i didn't admit
but he was trying to play good cop good
cop back up all i got to say is hooters
never got so much free publicity in
their lives
yeah that's stupid hooters stock was
like game stop
that's awesome oh that's great man i
didn't realize latinos could turn on
their own
like that in such a small town uh all
right guys thank you very much for
coming in and uh
congratulations ahead of you cheers
thank you very much love you brother i
love you
thank you bye
all right wait a minute so because of
your long-winded [ __ ]
this is now a two-part show yeah you're
welcome everybody
yeah you know what i mean yeah we're
gonna have to do this in two parts like
got a little long-willed
well i guess it was me can i tell you
something about your relationship when
you got married you married a quiet
latina in five years you became the
quiet latina
i am definitely quite a latina all right
that was part one
and uh or was that was that part two was
that part one this stuff is delicious
you